star studded casts pandemic nightmares
and a puppet that costs more than a
mansion can TV shows possibly get more
expensive than this taking the grand
prize for the most expensive television
production to date is the Lord of the
Rings the rings of power which came in
at a whopping 58 million dollars per
episode an epic high fantasy series
based on the world of J.R.R Tolkien the
rings of power takes place Millennia
before the events of the hobbits and the
Lord of the Rings when the rights to a
Tolkien TV series first went up for
grabs a bidding water rub dip between
major streamers HBO Amazon and Netflix
with Amazon beating out its Rivals with
a hefty bed of 250 million dollars this
could be the beginning of a new era for
our people in a world of AR sound stages
and green screens the rings of power
stands out for its elaborate sets and on
location shoots which production
designer Ramsey Avery says are meant to
capture the Golden Age of Middle Earth
long before sauron's villainous
Shenanigans start to drag everything
down factor in the elaborate costumes
and full-scale Ensemble casts and you've
got a recipe for the priciest series
ever made in fact with a grand total of
five seasons ordered and already planned
in their entirety the show's total
budget could come in at more than a
billion dollars that's a time when
Netflix has been tightening its purse
strings one show that the platform was
funneled endless money into it's a hit
Supernatural sci-fi series stranger
things since the show's six million
dollar per episode freshman season
Netflix has gradually increased its
budget while continuing to ramp up the
killer computer generated and practical
effects not only that but by 2018
several of the show's casts were taking
home paychecks of around 250k to 350k
per episode it's estimated that the
price tag for the fourth season came in
at around 30 million dollars per episode
according to Netflix executive Ted
sarandos a hefty chunk of season 4
spending increase can be attributed to
kovid which between the need for extra
protocol and Productions shutdowns hit
the budget hard still it was money well
spent the show features some of the most
beautiful CGI out there and is a
testament to the truly cinematic quality
a well-executed streaming series can
have this attention to detail even
earned stranger things the Emmy for best
prosthetic makeup in 2022
Beckham pre-quartered Taylor Sheridan's
hit series Yellowstone 1923 follows the
Dutton family during the tumultuous
years leading up to the Great Depression
comparing his latest show to Lawrence of
Arabia in terms of scale Sheridan told
deadline I don't know what the Game of
Thrones budgets were but I don't know
how they could have been more than this
one of the show's Big Ticket items is
its curse an ensemble led by Hollywood
Legends hello mirin and Harrison Ford
but this is just the beginning to create
the sense of life on a Montana Ranch the
series uses thousands of real cattle and
sheep and much of 1923 was filmed in a
span of overseas locations including
Malta Tanzania Kenya and South Africa
filming during the pandemic also meant
that covered Protocols of the budget
even further then of course you've got
the added cost of a historical series
it's no mean feat to build in dress sets
for a show set 100 years in the past the
grand total for this gorgeously rendered
drama comes in at around 30 million
dollars per episode good this time
all right okay
let's give him hell the MCU Disney plus
series Hawkeye racked up a 150 million
dollar price tag during its six episode
run which comes out at around 25 million
dollars per episode for the sake of
comparison Captain Marvel one of
Marvel's theatrical releases boasted a
budget of around 152 million dollars as
with many other big budget TV shows one
of Hawkeye's major cast was its star
power Jeremy Renner who reprises his
role as a titular Avenger is one of the
higher paid actors in the Marvel
Universe while his salary for the series
isn't widely known parade reported that
the actor made 50 million dollars for
Avengers end game and likely took home a
similar paycheck for Hawkeye as the
series was primarily filmed in New York
City Georgia and Ontario they weren't
exactly dropping much of the budget on
hauling an entire casting crew from one
exotic location to the next however as
is the case with many MCU shows and
movies hawakai will have required a
significant amount of CGI which always
ramps up budget judging by the
controversy stemming from the
disappointing effects in episode 3
however as well as greater complaints
about pay and working conditions from
Marvel VFX teams it seems that this is
one area in which the franchise
shouldn't be cutting costs as the first
Marvel series to be released on Disney
plus and the first of the mcu's phase 4
One Division was a much hyped and well
received entry into the Marvel Canon
like the comics themselves the MCU keeps
things fresh by serving up a variety of
genres and storytelling Styles and one
division is a stunning example of this
starring Elizabeth Olsen has won the
maximoff and Paul Bettany as Vision the
series finds a pair trapped in a strange
alternate reality the looks and feels
like a laugh track sitcom as the
episodes progress appear transitions
from one decade to the next traveling
through says since Fire by some of the
20th Century's most beloved TV shows
an unusual couple you know oh I don't
think that was ever in question
like other Marvel shows one division was
given a generous budget of about 25
million dollars per episode and it shows
besides the lead Duos inevitably
impressive earnings the show featured
400 shots of the effects created by a
team of 100 or so compositors the
sequence in which Vision flies around
Westview for example took months to
produce and effects like that don't come
cheap
yet another entry in Marvel's Disney
plus lineup Loki finds a god of Mischief
joining the time variance authority to
repair the damage to the timeline course
when he swiped the tesseracts in
Avengers end game this wickedly fun time
travel twister is one of the best recent
offerings from Marvel Studios although
with a budget of about 25 million
dollars per episode it certainly wasn't
cheap as you've probably guessed Loki
Stars Tom Hiddleston as the mcu's
favorite trickster and considering he
was reported to have been paid 8 million
dollars for his very brief role in
Avengers Infinity War it's safe to say
that a decent chunk of the show's budget
went toward his paycheck all that money
at least seems to have paid off however
many fans and critics agree that the
series felt more like a film than a TV
show and the first season was nominated
for six semis including one for costumes
and another for outstanding production
design perhaps unsurprisingly the Falcon
in the Winter Soldier enjoyed a
comparable budget to One Division and
Loki at around 25 million dollars per
episode the show takes place at few
months after Avengers end game which
ended with Sam Wilson taking up Captain
America's shield Anthony Mackey and
Sebastian Stan reprise their roles from
the movies and the show didn't exactly
skimp on its Supporting Cast either not
only that but the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier was partly filmed in the Czech
Republic and the covert outbreak of 2020
completely halted production for several
months too likely adding a significant
number to the show's final cast while
some critics felt the show's early
pacing could have been better overall it
drew praise for its social commentary
and the chemistry between its leading
actors Falcon and the winter soldiers
budget is clearly well spent too making
it an enjoyable series overall even if
it isn't the strongest limited series
Marvel has produced
these days a Blockbuster movie budget is
hardly a rarity in the world of TV
production in 2001 however it was
practically unheard of produced by
Steven Spielberg and Tom Hanks Band of
Brothers was the most expensive
television production to date with a
budget of 125 million dollars which
would be closer to 200 million dollars
today a 10-part mini-series follows Easy
Company a group of World War II
paratroopers from the 101st Airborne
Division from training through their
deployment on D-Day and ultimately to
the very end of the war a large portion
of Band of Brothers budget went to
support the massive ensemble cast many
of whom were relatively unknown at the
time of filming but have since gone on
to become famous faces today
looks like you guys gonna be surrounded
we're paratroopers Lieutenant they're
supposed to be surrounded in the
interest of depicting the war as
accurately as possible the filmmakers
and casts consulted many of easy
companies surviving veterans invested in
authentic uniforms and equipment and
poured plenty of cash into realistic
private techniques the effort paid off
with many World War II veterans and
history experts alike agreeing that the
series presented one of the most
accurate portrayals of world war film
ever produced the Pacific is a 2010
production that serves as a companion
piece to Band of Brothers much like a
solder sibling the Pacific became the
most costly television series ever
produced at the time of its release in
total HBO spent around 217 million
dollars according to co-executive
producer Tony tow the commitment to
realistically filming battle scenes was
tremendous take the landing of pelaliyu
for example which took four days to film
and came in under budget at around 5
million dollars the scene featured
upwards of 300 actors each of whom was
cladim perfectly duplicated 1940s
military uniforms that have been
Faithfully crafted on period Looms on
top of the cost of working with a large
cast producers had to factor in pricey
practical effects props and pyrotechnics
with production costs coming in at
around 270 thousand dollars per filming
day fortunately producers were able to
cash in on rebates by filming in
Australia slashing the show's total
costs by about 20 million dollars
House of the Dragon is a prequel to
HBO's absurdly successful fantasy Drama
Series Game of Thrones and like Game of
Thrones House of the Dragon features an
extra large ensemble cast of several
dozen actors many of whom are already
well established names and filming began
the first season's budget was around 200
million dollars which comes out to about
20 million dollars per episode in
comparison the budget for the final
season of Game of Thrones was around 15
million dollars per episode fans of
George RR Martin will be glad to know
that Westeros is getting the treatment
it deserves after cost cutting led to
some not so flattering moments in Game
of Thrones with Martin noting the first
season small-scale jousting tournament
as a particular disappointment judging
by the incomparable Tony in House of the
Dragon it's clear that the producers are
going out of their way to avoid making
the same mistake twice the first of
several live-action Star Wars shows to
be released on Disney plus the
Mandalorian is a space Western set a few
years after Return of the Jedi this is
the way
this is the way
this is the way a few factors accounted
for the show's price tag which equated
to roughly 15 million dollars per
episode not least of which was its
Production Studio A Mandalorian was the
first series of pioneer stagecraft
technology a type of all-around AR wall
that allows actors to work against
computer-generated backdrops the key
benefit of this technology is that it
creates more realistic lighting rather
than forcing the VFX team to duplicate
it when working with a green screen
among the show's more surprising
expenses was grogu rather than dump a
creepy CGI creature into the series
producers chose to go old school Star
Wars with a Twist by investing in a foot
tall robotic puppy one that costs 5
million dollars to build
the book of Boba Fett at the Disney plus
Star Wars series that serves as a
spin-off to the Mandalorian the story
follows the iconic Bounty Hunter Boba
Fett as he takes over Jabba the Hutt's
criminal organization on Tatooine while
the seven episode series wasn't as well
received as a Mandalorian it came with a
similar price tag of around 50 million
dollars an episode while the book of
Boba Fett doesn't have a multi-million
dollar puppet on Deck it does have its
own costly mascot of sorts in the
uncannonly young Luke Skywalker although
the aiding technology is improving as it
becomes more widely used it remains a
costly investment for any production
besides smoothing out the effects of
time with CGI the show's many Tech
experts also use an application called
re-speecher to rewind time on Luke's
voice since vocal cords tend to change
over time the final result well the
jury's out on that one